enfin sujet alors il est aussi fascinant
que bouleversant moi je trouve ce sujet
puisque dans c'est au programme sur
france 2 on a fait la connaissance d'une
jeune femme qui s'appelle amandine
amandine c'est une femme qui a connu un
déni de grossesse il ya à peine un an
c'est un phénomène mystérieux qui
toucherait plusieurs centaines de femmes
chaque année on regarde on en parle
juste après il y a un nom amandine
découvre sa grossesse alors qu'elle est
enceinte depuis presque six mois mais
aucun symptôme n'était survenu pour lui
indiquer qu'elle portait un enfant elle
a vécu un déni de grossesse aux
résultats de la prise de sang j'avais un
taux dans le même temps grossesse à plus
de onze mille ou quoi mais a prescrit
une échographie et d'urgence j'étais
enceinte de 5 mois voire quasiment six
mois mon ventre s'arrondissait pas vu
qui s'arrondit en sortant de
l'échographie à ce moment là ça s'est vu
mais pas avant j'étais totalement choqué
pendant quasiment quarante huit heures
mon compagnon je pense qu'il m'a pas cru
de toute façon à six mois il n'y avait
plus grand chose à faire à part à
accueillir cet enfant aujourd'hui cette
mère de famille est comblé par théo née
de ce déni et elle attend même un nouvel
enfant alors je trouve ce phénomène
assez bouleversant assez fascinant ils
concernent entre 800 et 2000 femmes à
chaque année entre une grossesse une et
trois grossesses sur 1000 concerné et
donc six cas sur 10 les femmes étaient
toujours dans ce trou et donc elle
n'avait aucun signe avant coureur
et vous avez entendu cette jeune femme
qui dit mon ventre et bien été tout plat
et puis appartement où l'on m'a annoncé
la grossesse
vim j'ai eu un ventre de femme enceinte
jean michel c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît depuis longtemps on connaissait
assez régulièrement de temps en temps on
est amené à faire un diagnostic à
l'échographie on surprend la personne en
lui disant qu'elle a un enfant
on a deux cas de figure possibles
première premier cas de figure c'est
l'ignorance a l'air d'être le cas donc
elle n'a pas vu elle continuait à avoir
ses règles et ses et deuxième cas de
figure celle angoisse que suscite une
grossesse chez certaines femmes de
s'occuper d'un enfant
la honte des tas de choses comme ça et
là elle préfère imaginer qui a pas
d'enfant elle refile enfants étaient à
bord d'un porte bien sûr
lewis était arrivé à sheryfa luna la
chercheuse lachance qui venait de
remporter popstars en 2007 et donc elle
se lance dans la promo l'enregistrement
de l'album et tout ça et au bout d'un
moment elle va consulter un médecin et
de mettre son ultime en fait
mademoiselle vous êtes enceinte et elle
s'était rendue compte de rien ça a été
très mal perçu d'ailleurs à l'époque
parce que justement il avait avait
investi beaucoup d'argent sur elles ont
fait ce qu'ils ont à dire à une femme on
perçoit mal votre grossesse par sa mère
ou sa certains avaient même dit bah du
coup maintenant tu vas avorté parce
qu'on a mis tellement d'argent sur toi
que voilà tu y vas tu va inventer l a
refusée bien évidemment et alors elle a
raconté ça sur plusieurs plateaux et ça
et c'était assez émouvant où elle disait
gt gt tout là que j'étais je ressentais
rien et du moment où l'asie pousse
jamais un moment ca seront en fait j'en
ai dit non c'est non mais j'imagine mois
la violence que l'ânesse fait quand
quand l'annoncé faite aux femmes de en
fait vous êtes enceinte quand on est
enceinte de six mois sept mois face ça
doit être un choc terrible en fait un
double choc un violent choc pour la
personne et il ya le choc pour le
médecin parce que on comprend pas que
quelqu'un soit enceinte et ne le sache
pas donc temps en temps le médecin il
est super d en parler et il sait pas ce
qu'il doit dire à ses dires et à qui il
doit le dire parce qu'il m'a vite dans
certaines situations une pensée aussi à
tous les papas qui sont eux aussi en
état de choc
aussi j'ai de la situation et le teil
aussi pour la jeune femme
peut-être que son conjoint ne la croient
pas en disant non mais tu m'as menti tu
savais que tu étais enceinte comment tu
pourrais améliorer aussi
non je sais pas bah non mais une fois
qu'on a dit tout ça et je suis bien
évidemment d'accord je pense que c'est
très choquant c'est aussi très pratique
pardon d'être enceinte que pendant trois
mois avait pas pensé à ça pendant neuf
mois quand même on a on a des exigences
on se plaint on comprenait je suis
fatigué je suis sincère ce formidable de
pouvoir se plaindre en tenant les normes
et membre du coup du coup je
je me suis dit ni bhl quand vous étiez
enceinte ou non franchement moi je suis
pas du tout heureux époux le très bien
franchement je finis fait recours n'est
rien j'ai eu des petites exigences et
puis finalement comme j'ai accouché très
longtemps avant la fin de mon père m'a
vous voyez j'ai pas j'ai pas fais chier
grand monde d'accord très bon dites nous
ce que vous en pensez avec le hashtag
sécu dlt sur ce déni de grossesse qui
effectivement moi je trouve un phénomène
assez fascinant psychologiquement enfin
ça ça met en cause plein de choses
hashtag sécu des lt